which uh Golden State Warrior at any
time you answered you think you can get
to answer the phone
it's difficult
um
like if it's real close if someone said
I have a million dollars you have to get
a warrior to answer the phone
Who you calling
clay clay uh I mean that's a good word
to you know to you know those are my
brothers like yeah I mean like you would
have to give me a time frame like all
right give me a window yeah like give me
a window of time like you know what I'm
saying but pretty much
pretty Gary's going to answer anytime
who's now back on the team you know so
so Gary Gary's going to answer any time
were you chat with his with his dad yes
of course yes
um GPS from Oakland for sure
um he's working all that [__] talking me
and Steph me and Steph are like super
close like me and Steph have a super
close relationship man but you know this
is we have to be mindful of who Steph
Curry is
yeah so it's like I'm not just oh yeah
that's a that's a tough thing like to be
like oh yes Steph's gonna answer that
you know I would be lying right uh but
will he text back and will he call of
course so it just has to be a time
window though man but I I pretty have a
a great relationship with all of the
fellas man you know um you know Dre's
little bro and we just continue to keep
building man you know I love those guys
um for you
is it frustrating is a Warriors fan to
see they're like the number one
bandwagon team now in the last like
decade no and I'm like nobody was ruined
for the [__] Warriors when it was
Monta Ellis right and David Lee and then
before that it was like Steven Jackson
you know even when it was like Run DMC
right nobody was was there but now it's
like they're like you know the the IT
team did do you get frustrated to see
like bandwagon Warrior fans not at all
that's what winning does
um you know you you want to be able to
say man let's continue to expand the
bandwagon man let's keep going that lets
us know that we're winning
um you have Yankee fans that probably
can't tell you one person on the team
they just love it and Cowboys fans you
got Cowboys fans you know all of these
franchise man you know the like the
Patriots of course the Lakers fans I've
seen so many Bay Area people that I know
that were Lakers yeah most definitely
was Lakers a lot of them
you're full of [__] what's up bro I grew
up my dad
Magic Johnson I had a Magic Johnson
Jersey at four I'm like come on man cut
it out but uh you know it is what it is
like we you that's what comes with
winning man um I definitely salute the
fans that have were there during the
tough times and you know
um that's what I'm happy about I'm just
happy to see some of those people still
going strong yeah for sure shout out to
what was his name bertrands what was the
guy's name the big German [__] Center
the white boys
yeah whatever he was Lithuania
could exist yeah
people forget that he was an All-Star
right but he's just like he wasn't an
All-Star but he was good but he led the
league and uh and field goal percentage
pretty good man pretty good dude it's
like Slovakian Lithuanian something like
that he was pretty good and his wow his
girl oh my God we got to see if we could
find a picture of her man his girl was
so fine oh my God
so yeah I remember those days